things are better the world is better
just because there's not a war doesn't
mean there's peace he's coming some call
him apocalypse he was some kind of God
for thousands of years he's been
amassing mutants to take their powers
he always had four followers like the
four horsemen Eric don't join them
whatever it is you think you saw in me I
buried it with my family together we
will cleanse the earth everything
they've built will fall and from the
ashes of their power like this before
it took him present the world needs the
x-men I'm not a hero
students backup team if I'm going to
teach your kid something I'm going to
teach them how to fight huh I'm not
afraid of them
I need oh he's my father what never my
mom yeah I know
not all of us can control our powers
then don't
apocalypse means to destroy this world
it's all of us against a god and the
most powerful beings on earth
forget everything you think you know
none of that
you're not students anymore
love taking everything from that
well you've been busy we had a little
help from the in-n-out reader confidence
Helens in Buddha and Titan goddess the
grounders for fiance in towson tiananmen
world is facing the porn border their
honor Esther